we've asked people of all different sort
of origins ethnicities uh immigrants
what they think and we've noticed that a
lot of uh sort of upper middle class
white people so it's because of the
racism here
and then people who lived abroad said uh
it is worse elsewhere would you say that
south korea as it comes to diversity or
tolerance of people would you say it
says
say america is more racist than south
korea
no
not at all
this one's really basic that time of
year is upon us and
we all know how the media
and our representatives would describe
america
america is a nation that can be defined
in a single word
i was going to put him
okay that's cute but i took to the
streets in a very diverse area to see
how americans would describe america and
their pride in it and if there's one
lesson to take away
marginalized communities minorities
don't let old white guys speak for you
[Music]
all right happy fourth
you have big plans
full time right that's up you guys proud
to be american
yeah there you go god bless have a good
fourth man
we actually proud to be american
i'm proud to be american well at least
i've been free you're proud to be an
american you're so uh you know that's
all we're asking people so greatest
country in the world
[Music]
all right god bless man
all right so fate and laura right all
right so fourth of july obviously i see
the hat yeah let me ask you are you uh
both would you consider yourself proud
to be american absolutely yeah yeah yeah
why absolutely why because we freedom we
i'm gonna tell you like this we were
homeless
for s for a long time a long time yeah
you wouldn't recognize this
if it wasn't for the fact the
determination and some of the people out
here helping us giving us this that the
other every nine year man we would have
drowned yeah and god will be out here
we were blessed
by an american
to get moved from here to waterloo iowa
with jobs
with um
nice to meet you you went to waterloo
that's where we live now let me ask this
house
just where you live now yeah were you
nervous when you first went because that
is i've spent time it's an incredibly
white area we were we were nervous you
know tell you that we were nervous
because of the the the change we were
making right didn't care about anything
hard yeah it was hard it didn't matter
about anything else do you like it there
yeah we love it yeah people are really
nice yeah oh they're oh they're
wonderful they're way beyond that
wonderful yeah like people will ask you
are you okay what are you doing today
and do you feel like over there in iowa
i mean obviously it's it's incredibly
white because it's just look at iowa
history and farmers and yeah it's
changed a little bit uh it crosses
racial boundaries people are nice there
yeah but you gotta understand it's a
blue cross waterloo is a blue collar
state right
blue collar when it comes to blue collar
when it comes to blue collar man
sometimes people
they don't think about anything else
right what i'm saying and that's and
that's that's the way the world should
be yeah you know when you start thinking
about color and all that kind of stuff
it changes yeah because then because
then what people started thinking is
that
their their their their blood is
different their blood is a different
color than yours are you two a couple
yeah
you might move it in closer so i can
just so that way i don't have to keep
doing the microphone
this year how long have you been married
four years four years number 16. okay
and how long have you been together oh
oh
seven
seven years did you and did you did you
meet in iowa or you met you know what i
got i came i came from las vegas okay i
got shot five times in my vehicle
um why did that happen
it's it's a long story it's a long story
i was trying to help somebody out get
their life back on track because i was i
was doing really good at the time and uh
i tried to help them out and they
flipped on me and uh i'm from wisconsin
with my mom okay i have family in
wisconsin and we met on the same street
oh wow
and before we know 20 years prior to
that we walked the same alleys the same
streets and all of that right by each
other and didn't even know each other so
you you were both homeless
at one point and now you're doing well
you're in iowa you're working uh at
tyson foods yeah
and that's an incredible that's an
incredible story let me ask you this do
you think um
do you think that's a story that maybe
people need to hear a little more as far
as the united states
we hear a lot of the negative but the
truth is there's no country in the world
with more class mobility than the united
states absolutely and and yeah because
you know what when it comes to when it
comes to homeless people sometimes
people look at
the drug part the the alcohol park and
all that kind of stuff don't get me
wrong there there is that out here you
know what i'm saying
and when you see the same person over
and over and over again asking for the
same thing over and over again of course
you're going to be like come on man this
is not it you know what i mean but at
the same time though sometimes
compassion comes when you get a person
that never never looks at a homeless
because of what they heard it's more
stereotype right you know what i'm
saying but when you actually give a
person a chance and just reach out and
say you know what this is going to
happen i got i got 50 cents i got a
dollar yeah it's not going to happen
every day right you know what i'm saying
but i just got something for you to help
you know it's pretty sad obviously there
are a lot of job programs even here in
texas and and unfortunately
the majority of the homeless population
don't show up for work after the second
week i'm sure you're probably aware of
this but see i understand that that that
that makes the other guys or other
people like us
or other people that aren't doing drugs
and doing things of that nature yeah
look at that yeah changing their life
right now it's like
my my husband's a hairstylist has been
happy i've been doing it for five years
and
you know we like i don't know and i lost
my mom
uh
two years ago right after coving and it
just dropped us all the way back down to
downhill but i'll tell you we have met
some beautiful people all the way from
here to iowa and it's just amazing and
that's the only reason we came down here
because the security guards over there
are awesome
yeah that's really good
when you run into people that
work security and
have to tell another person hey you need
to get off this property get off that
property but they still take the time to
talk to you yeah help you out listen to
your story if you need something they'll
be there
that's what kind of um
that's what you need yeah and i'll tell
you and and anyone out here
that
we're close to um
that took us under their wing they knew
they knew we were homeless right
and um and they didn't judge us and i
mean i can just this one here merit the
security category we literally used to
push a basket yeah yeah
in a in a grocery cart basket with my
little
my little lizzy here oh wow that's your
okay that's my service animal she's so
well behaved and yes my dog's a little
bigger than that
my dog is 110 yeah you know because of
the generosity and because of the
encouragement and just because of the
goodness in these people's hearts that's
what makes people proud
we're back strong and
and that's that's what america is us
that's what america is supposed to
always be about it's supposed to be
looking after
your fellow man
how much do you think uh
you talked about being blessed yeah i'm
assuming that you guys are believers how
much do you think that the you know
founding judeo-christian principles even
though everyone is flawed some of the
founders are flawed how much do you
think that contributes to
what it is that you love about america i
think it's all about faith you know what
i'm saying it's definitely about faith i
mean a person can look at a doorknob and
say you know what i believe that
doorknob is going to take me farther
than i need you know what i'm saying
yeah well
what i'm saying is that's how far faith
goes when you believe in god and you
believe in christianity and you believe
in all these different things
then you believe so much that you just
let him have it yeah and he closed doors
and also your point of view you know to
give you an example so uh what's
lizzie's name of your daughter
okay so i have 110 pound dog and uh he's
i shouldn't say he's a rescue i took him
from a family who they just couldn't
take care of he's also a rescue okay
well he came from a good family i want
to be clear it's just they also had
another dog that these two dogs didn't
get along
so he had just been in a fight with this
dog and they had a baby and they're like
they're both good dogs they're like
boiling water right so i got him and he
had like cuts over his face and uh his
name was louis i was like i need to
change his name a little bit right so
this goes back to the point of view i
named him joe lewis after my favorite
boxer of all time he said look at me
okay and uh i had one person black
person say hi man what is that are you
saying that joe lewis is a dog
no i'm saying it's my favorite boxer and
this is my right this is my favorite
non-human being
sentient being on earth right and it's
that's exactly horrible it's
right when i look at it that that way
and it goes and i'm saying this from
both sides yeah
sometimes people take things out of
perspective right you know i mean you
know they they say
just because you're white you shouldn't
name something like you said joe lewis
he's a black guy you name your dog joe
lewis so suppose i named my dog
hitler
you know what i'm saying so what right
i'm an american i should be able to do
it exactly i mean i'm not saying i would
do that no no no i'm saying that name
you can't scratch off the list as an
american as as as as as what we were
thought what what our for our
forefathers fought for yeah was free
from freedom
and say the things that you want not say
pretty much where you want to do what
you want to do
you know what you shouldn't do this
because of that and you know who fought
for freedom people don't realize this
joe lewis yeah uh i ask people sometimes
they say hey who's the greatest
heavyweight botch of all time and the
reason i actually
borderline obsessed with joe lewis is if
you listen to everyone felix muhammad
ali mike tyson go he's the guy if you
want to watch perfect form right he had
25 title defenses yeah but he had a
fight against a guy named max schmeling
yes he did he talked he had it for he
had never lost until this guy max
schmeling who was german knocked him out
right and then before he was he was
drafted going into world war ii okay and
he was having a rematch versus
matchmaker so everyone knows about jesse
owens right but people don't realize
that joe lewis was fighting max schmell
and hitler said schmeling's going to
beat you know at that point said the
american negro it's going to this is
going to show the superiority of the
aryan race right the president even said
to joe lewis and this is before he's
about to go over to war yeah this is the
biggest selling
live gate of all time joe lewis versus
the one guy who beat his ass before the
president said you gotta win this one
for the morale of the country
imagine that pressure right and the
entire country
i mean loved joelos he was the most
popular uh athlete beloved athlete in
the country right and in the rematch he
knocked him out right with that short
right on the jaw
and uh it was a big deal to the point
where they said okay joe lewis instead
of going instead of putting a rifle in
your hands we'll let you go and do like
you know help morale with the troops and
teach boxing i think he earned that
right but a lot of time when people say
and it's true this is a flawed country
and there's a history of people who are
racist but if you read joe lewis's
biography it's fascinating um when he
talks about moving from the south and
moving to detroit yeah he talks talks
about how things changed and how
how he just felt support across the
board he's like i met some bad people i
met mostly good people yes
you have to remember this is the time
during world war ii where
they all rallied behind me again
what i've learned and this one right
here taught me this is that i can't i
can't
i can't
get mad at your feelings how you feel
about me
right what you say to me and how you
respond to me when i'm asking for this
or if i'm asking for that just say god i
can't get upset with that because you
have that right right and it took me a
long time to realize i used to get so
mad because we were hungry and i was
like can can i get some change for food
and this thing no no leave me alone baby
boy that she's been i'm sorry but he's
one of my favorites oh is it okay yeah
she's been spit at she's been told a lot
of different things but
she told me that when i stoop to their
level that makes me know better than
them so why get mad at them yeah so i
changed that and i started saying you
know when people when people didn't
respond the way i wanted to respond i
just left it alone yeah and what did
what it happened i'm sorry what happened
to me is i changed yeah and i changed
and i became the person that i was
trying to make that person become yeah
you know and and what it did is it said
you know what i can't change the next
person i can't change the way they think
how they feel what they what they say
how they say it because if i'm not if
i'm not a different person yeah then why
should i ask somebody else to be
different it comes down to personal
responsibility and accountability and
accounting even if other people are bad
they're going to be black people that's
right man i got to tell you your story
warms my heart i'm glad to know that you
two are doing better yeah i hope you
have a great fourth of july oh yeah oh
yeah and it's it's was it laura and fate
yes laura and fate all right go uh spend
some time there with baby boy
bye lexi is it no lizzie lizzy all right
hey thank you man i appreciate it have a
good fourth minute safe travels
[Music]
we're just asking people about the
fourth of july you know about america
what's your name man my name's phillip
jones phillip phillip jones philip nice
to meet you do you mind uh hey it's the
fourth of july coming up
uh let me ask you are you proud to be an
american yeah yeah what makes you proud
to be an american well born and raised
in seattle washington
and
it's like
been on the streets like for 30 plus
years
well you've been on the streets for 30
plus years you think oh well
parents were taking my social security
checks
so
i decided if i live on the streets
nobody gets it
okay but that backfired for me because
went to prison gang
yeah gave up
the whole criminal life in 2011 yeah
except the christ in prison good for you
man
and
it's like
20
21 okay god delivered me all the way
from here from seattle to here do you
prefer it here
it's pretty hot it's hot it is hot but
people aren't they're not all uh pricks
like they're at seattle a lot of people
well i've spent some time in seattle
they're not all the nicest folks for me
in seattle it's like
actually my wife was from seattle okay
then i see black okay then i come down
here and just ask that question go black
yeah and you guys are barely around
no it's pretty it's much more mixed yeah
yeah so you said you've been on the
streets now for 30 plus years you got
out of the criminal life that sounds to
me like you're saying it was it was a
choice for you to be in the streets
because of your upbringing um we just
spoke with fate you know and laura it
seems like you know them where they were
also you know living on the streets and
now they've you know
found employment and really kind of
turned it around do you think your next
step is you're gonna you're gonna get a
job and i was in a christian program
like a couple of christians from denton
texas here came up from seattle on a a
missionary trip
rescued me and my fiance
she's still in the christian program up
from then okay
um
i got kicked out because i don't take
authority what man you got it up they're
helping you well yeah but when you're on
the streets that long right the first
program i ever been in
and
i'm still in the word though yeah still
in the word
i've got a bracelet here that says i
know the plans that i have for you yeah
not to hurt you no not to harm you but
to help you right yeah from jeremiah 29
11.
so what do you think the plans are for
you i know you don't do it with
authority but well
you know it's not a good choice to stay
in the streets it sounds to me like
you're acknowledging that
you've chosen to yeah and you seem like
a sharp enough guy
you could go to work and not be on the
streets well i'm working on my own
website
okay
what's the website i need a fat bench in
seattle
i got more fun it's funny i need a fat
[ __ ] in seattle i don't know if that's
a way to make a living just sounds like
a way to find a fat [ __ ] yeah but i got
a lot of followers
yeah i hope one of them is your fiance
well yeah is your fiancee fat [ __ ]
no shanna she can't be she can't be
happy with that she's she's a big woman
okay so if it's your fiance it's a big
woman if it's a stranger it's a fat
[ __ ]
no a fat [ __ ] is a female dog oh okay
so that so you're you're looking to uh
you're creating an animal rescue yeah
all right man well that's that's pretty
funny but i do hope that uh you know you
spend some more time with fate and uh
laura man uh
i'd like to see you you've made some
seems like you made some some better
choices you're making some steps
come on you don't need to be here on the
streets yeah i'm working on myself
mostly right and getting close to god
yeah
but at a certain point you know what you
know what god says about uh about a man
who doesn't work
he doesn't eat
oh i eat
and i work well you know who really eats
them fat [ __ ] yeah yeah save them for
the rest of us all right well thanks man
i appreciate it yeah let's see uh
let's see do you have a bible
oh yeah okay i was gonna say if you
don't have one get one for you um what
can we uh can we write let's get your
info and what's i know it's gotta be
hard to reach you probably but is it
there at the christian working den is
your fiance someone we can reach well
she didn't didn't yeah in the program
then freedom house okay and
i'm always in this neighborhood okay
what would you say if uh you know we
were willing to maybe help
find you a job and follow up with you is
that something you'd be amenable to yeah
okay what's the best way for us to to
reach you do you think is there i'm in
the neighborhood just in this
neighborhood yeah the security know me
all right
but if we do that you're gonna you know
we work a job that means there's gonna
be some form of authority you're gonna i
know i know it's hard i have a general
problem with authority too but
that's why i'm my own boss now but yeah
you still you gotta work your way up
yeah all right well listen man have a
good fourth stay in the shade though it
gets i'm already black and man i'm
getting darker
[Music]
what's your name i'm sinclair sinclair
yes oh wow i've only that's your first
name yes sir i've only heard that as a
last name
uh yeah there's a couple authors like
sinclair lewis i don't know i was that's
why but some other author has names for
things okay i've known a lot of
sinclair's up so you said you have a
family cookout yeah is that a tradition
you do uh
sometimes my brother's doing a cookout
in greenville and so he lives in
greenville which is up in uh you know
upper north texas yeah and uh we used to
have more cookouts when i lived in east
texas and i would have friends come over
and like was it be a big affair with
fireworks we can't do that because we
live in the city now oh yeah they got
the laws
yeah i got some friends coming up also i
know we're gonna have like a big dinner
and then like uh after that i'm gonna go
up to greenville okay what are you
cooking
no ribs man yeah
i mean i need to go there i don't have
anything planned yet for the fourth i've
been working uh let me ask you so fourth
of july you guys have this uh tradition
that you do it sounds pretty that's what
a lot of americans do yeah uh
question we're asking everyone is you
proud to be american yes yeah you are
what makes you proud to be american
uh
proud to be american
just because you know i believe this is
the only
country that allows
you to do exactly what you want to do
yeah yeah i mean with that said i feel
like you got to start your race some
people
start their race at certain positions in
life yeah um that's not fair but it is
what it is but you can you can climb up
and you really can
like do what you need to do yeah that's
a very optimistic that's a very hopeful
view which uh i think is a big part of
what makes america america
think about it right we've left with the
world's most powerful nation we were
like we're not going to do that anymore
we had no idea if this was going to work
you know but it sounds like it's been
working for a lot of people let me ask
you this the question is not is it a
perfect country because i'm going to
both agree it's not
would you say that the united states is
the greatest country in the world right
now
um defined great
uh
yeah yeah it just means that you know
the country you would most prefer to
live in
if that's the definition there's only
one country i want to live in which is
america okay but i do think there are
other countries that do a lot of the
things better than america okay and i
hope that america can adopt some of
those type of things i think it would
make our country even better right i
don't necessarily think there is a the
best or greatest country and maybe
if the situation was different i could
say that but
time and time again there are just
things that you like and dislike about
every country right right yeah but
you're still proud to be american let me
understand can i ask you what you do i'm
a video producer oh wow video bruce okay
so like these guys so this you're not
too unfamiliar yeah that's one of those
things i'm willing to bet you probably
you had to cut your teeth for a long
time independent contractor right and
it's yeah it's kind of sink or swim
sometimes sometimes
yeah that means uh
that means you believe in yourself man
that's pretty it's a tough thing to do i
know what it's like to go out there
without a net and not really have a job
job you know when you're a video
producer sometimes it's just you eat
what you killed yeah you you got hustle
you got a grind you can't you can't like
rest on your laurels no that's exactly
right it's sort of like with what i do
sometimes when we do uh stand up i
always say look that's a new audience
you have to start from scratch every
single time they don't know what you did
if it worked like your new boss doesn't
know that you did a really good let's
say film short film you know you produce
great effects last time but he's going
what are you doing now and uh if you
keep doing it well well then like you
said you can move up it's not flawless
but that's one thing i was raised in
canada that i do appreciate about the
united states i think people don't
realize there's not the same class
mobility as you outlined in other
countries those united states that's
what makes us unique yes that is what
makes us unique it's one of the few
countries where like you can start a
career stop a career change careers
uh and work hard and get done you know
i've heard about this uh like the
thousand uh it was a thousand hour
principle yeah a thousand principles
yeah yeah like i mean like to me
essentially that's kind of like college
for a lot of people yeah like if you
master a craft you can find ways to make
money with that crap yeah and that's a
that's invaluable and i really think
that you can't find a lot of places a
lot of places want to keep you in a
certain place same space and you can't
move up like you said yeah that's pretty
tough well all right man hey maybe we
can get your video every now and then we
do unless you're working as an employee
somewhere every now and then we need uh
independent
yeah give contractors to
to him he's a token i'm sorry his breath
probably smells like meat but you will
too after the fourth i see yeah yeah
thank you man all right thank you
sinclair i appreciate that
[Music]
this is what we're asking everyone here
uh are you proud to be american
absolutely yeah we're actually proud to
be american you can walk around you can
do things like this on a saturday
without any worries without anybody
or any people telling you what to do or
where you're supposed to be you have
your own free time to do things and you
can live and make money how you want
it's a pretty good answer
happy for us
now what's your channel sometimes oh
dude man hey good all right what's your
name
joseph
all right you have two minutes to talk
uh yeah all right joseph joseph he's
going to make me look stupid i didn't
know it i already know it i promise you
i'm not coming you know i don't know i
got you all right all right so joseph
it's just fourth of july okay happy
fourth by the way before it's happy
worth do you have big plans i do not no
just working just working okay uh you're
not gonna like grill or something and
spend some time with family friends no
no we don't really like you know
celebrated that much you know i'm just
oh why not i don't know i mean we're
asian you know like you know we're not
really in the american spirit you know
what i mean
come on it's like i don't know let me
ask you this then are you proud to be
american i am yeah yeah what makes you
to an extent yeah of course like you
know
america is like you know 100 a great
country right um but then again of
course you know as everyone knows like
you know
there's you know the highs and the lows
you know what i mean yeah no i mean the
question is not if it's a perfect
country yeah um would you say though
america is the greatest country in the
world not perfect
that's a hard one to be honest um i
can't really give you an honest opinion
on that because i'm not educated enough
i'm not gonna lie to you so i can't say
it's the greatest or it's not you know
what i mean yeah but well i would say
it's up there though yeah you said
you're asian american all right so what
kind of asian women i'm south korean oh
south korean okay so are you uh second
generation first generation first person
you came here from south korea yeah oh
there you go ginger snap right there he
spent a lot of time in south korea
yeah how long do you live in south korea
uh for three years oh three years so you
moved you're pretty young yeah okay uh i
was gonna ask if you contrasting which
one you preferred but you really
wouldn't be able to so i mean so i was
so i was there when i was a little kid
and then i also went back there for
middle school so okay so yeah so for two
or three years you went yeah yeah and uh
how would you compare it to the united
states where do you
oh 100 in the united states i mean i
feel like just the cultural shock was
very different you know um
i was just so used to living in the u.s
and then when i went back to the crew
when i went back to korea it was just a
totally different thing you know it was
good korea too yeah yeah i mean that
says a lot like yeah i mean i feel like
korea is very like a good place to like
you know tour and everything you know
just like you know have fun and all that
but like to go to school and all that no
i wouldn't say what do you mean as far
as like culture shock um
well one like you know
they would still hit you or at least
like the school that i went to you know
if you're running in the hallways they'd
stop you boom hit you yeah and stuff
like that you know it just wasn't but
what i was like really used to and then
also like um
if a guy is just like one year older
than you like you know like the respect
that you have to treat him with is very
different like you know here in the u.s
you could treat you know each other with
respect you know no problem but over
there it's like more of a they look down
on you just because they're older than
you know what i mean right so like you
know i really not like that the guy who
just hit you is looking down on you no
it's not no that's like the teachers
will hit me and then there's like this
one guy that's like a great above me
yeah just you know just shove you around
you know treat you like nothing and [ __ ]
and would you say was uh uh south korea
you know a lot of people sometimes we've
asked quite a few people here today
about the united states
and interesting because you lived in
south korea
for two separate uh i guess two separate
spells of about three years
we've asked people of all different sort
of origins ethnicities uh immigrants
what they think and we've noticed that a
lot of uh sort of upper middle class
white people so it's because of the
racism here and then people who lived
abroad
said it is worse elsewhere would you say
that south korea as it comes to
diversity or tolerance of people would
you say it says uh
say america's more racist than south
korea
no
not at all dude oh my god so
my parents are actually so i tell them
all the time but they are very racist
i'm not gonna lie like so so they work
so they work or they used to work at a
uh beauty supply yeah you know so the
people who would come in you know that
you know african-americans you know
would be the majority of the people that
come in and so they just have like this
like
you know
set you know right mindset on on
african-americans and i always tell them
like you know like no it's not like that
but you know even in the streets yeah i
would say south koreans are pretty
racist to other other other races and
it's very diverse in the united states
there is no racism but um maybe you
would say maybe sometimes americans take
it for granted that we uh have people of
so many different creeds and don't
realize how right it was a leading
question i know that in a lot of asian
countries they're yeah they can be
pretty racist of course yeah yeah
yeah i mean
yeah america 100 i would say is probably
the most diverse country that we have um
but then again
you feel like people have been pretty
accepting of you here's an asian
american sometimes yeah i mean um
when i was growing up not really no yeah
you know of course got bullied you know
the whole chick eyes stuff like that but
i mean the more that you grow up i guess
like you know i just got used to it yeah
kind of just like you know let it buy
you know right yeah so individual races
too maybe like because i was bullied too
but that's because i was an idiot
well you know they didn't have an eraser
like oh i can't fall back i'm saying
it's because of my race it's just they
don't like me
but
would you say probably overall more
forgiving than maybe how south koreans
might be to someone like let's say an
african-american living there
in their schools
i feel like okay so
south koreans come to the u.s they have
this mindset on african-americans but
let's say an african-american goes to
south korea they look at the
african-americans as like exotic they're
like wow like you know i would i
wouldn't say like in korea like if an
african-american goes to korea i don't
think they would get you know treated
bad right but you know yeah what about a
chinese person in south korea
no that'd be fine yeah what about like
japanese same thing yeah
yeah there's no there's no uh infighting
there yeah no i wouldn't say like you
know if anyone goes to south korea i
don't
i've never seen a problem i've never
heard of probably i'm pretty sure there
are of course you know me personally
i've never heard of anything but you
know south koreans coming to the us
seeing you know
this stuff that goes down it's more
determined by experience yeah of
unfortunately sometimes that leads to a
negative viewpoint that may not be
accurate but it's based on some personal
experiences yeah now look the good thing
is you're kind of you're more american
than korean in a lot of ways you can
work on your parents a little bit yeah
yeah yeah no i know i try i try my best
i try my best i really do yeah yeah no i
can imagine i uh i've uh we have some uh
koreans who work for us he's like my
parents like oh my gosh sometimes uh
depending on which girl i would bring
home he's like they would throw a fist
oh yeah 100 yeah and i don't really
experience that really with my family's
like white guy my parents never really
cared but he was like oh no it's a big
big difference there's a hierarchy yeah
i didn't know he he schooled me on all
of this i was an ignorant white american
well thank you brother i appreciate it
yeah everybody
[Music]
there you go just more proof that
one side of the country namely those in
power and the media want us divided if
they just leave us alone we'll get along
and realize that america is a pretty
good place
hey if you like this video hit that uh
notification bell
up there uh or subscribe or share this
right isn't that right dave smash that
like button and share it where would you
wear it what are you wearing there
that's nice oh this is uh i found it in
the trash yeah also known as
your shirt
crowdershop.com which is where you can
go and support and uh
we
we have overs we keep the overstock in
the trash
except for people who are little yeah he
says i haven't earned it yet because i
hadn't grown all the way by the way if
you find hunter biden's gun in there
just let it be